the conflict in ukraine has shone a
light on the uk's pre-existing energy
issues uk consumers are facing pretty
massive increases to their bills we have
obviously seen a big push into solar and
wind energy
but what a lot of people now say is
that's not going to be enough to meet
the uk's ambitious decarbonization
targets and as a result nuclear has come
back into favor bringing nuclear home
with one nuclear plant and one nuclear
reactor every year for eight years
rather than one a decade so i went to
anglesey which is an island off the
north west coast of wales they have a
nuclear reactor which is in the process
of decommissioning
and that site is one of the top
contenders for one of the first modular
reactors they're now talking about 25
of the uk's energy
coming from nuclear by 2050 anglesey has
been known as one of the least
productive places in the uk that is
partly because there's quite an aging
population there a lot of retirees and a
lot of young people leave to find work
elsewhere
small modular reactors are basically as
it sounds smaller versions of
traditional reactors importantly they're
modular which means they can be built
away from site in factories and then
transported to the site and what that
does is it brings down the costs so in
the uk the company that's
looking to make these reactors is rolls
royce they do have experience in nuclear
through their work
on the uk's nuclear submarines what the
supporters say
is that you know these are smaller than
the previous technology they're also
much newer technology and therefore they
argue that there is less risk a
government official said that a
breakdown in an atomic power plant in
pennsylvania today is probably the worst
nuclear reactor accident to date nuclear
has had safety concerns
stretching back decades and those aren't
going away and i mean personally i
didn't feel any risk from that but when
we spoke to some of the experts there
obviously
that safety risk is a big concern for
locals small modular reactors are
effectively an untested technology and
quite a lot of people in the industry
who are maybe a bit more skeptical refer
to these as powerpoint reactors because
none of them are are up and running yet
but i think broadly there is quite a lot
of support the local mp
ran on a platform to get the nuclear
site reopened the majority of my
constituents support wilvernowth it's
recognized as the best site in the uk
possibly the world to host a nuclear
power plant the most powerful argument i
heard for smrs was to do with the jobs
benefit i heard from one of the sources
that there are taxi drivers for example
on anglesey who were actually qualified
nuclear engineers but when the plants
decommissioned they didn't want to leave
the local area and so they've had to
move into into something else a lot of
local people have worked in nuclear they
have experience with it they've lived
near the plan and what was really
interesting is that you can see the
welsh government has already made some
efforts to
support the local economy around that
plant even while it's decommissioning so
there's there's quite a nice cafe
there's a coastal path so it's good to
kind of see a different image of nuclear
than what we might think of the most
powerful argument against i think is a
combination of the safety and the
environmental concerns and one thing i
heard from a couple of people i spoke to
was a sense that the westminster
government is quite happy to
encourage nuclear in places that are
quite far away from london
um you know a sense that they'll they'll
put it in wales but they won't put it on
their own back door
[Music]
you